une crise sanitaire sans précédent et on
sait d'avancé qu'on aura évidemment
beaucoup de familles qui ne pourront pas
partir en vacances
on a donc besoin d'accompagner sur le
plan social et bien les loisirs la cette
période estivale la manière dont on fait
revivre aussi la solidarité entre nous
et naturellement puisque beaucoup de
familles ne pourront pas partir en
vacances donner un accès privilégié aux
villes de loisirs paraît être un
instrument tout à fait important pour la
période estivale est donc naturellement
on a discuté et j'ai fait cette
proposition pour liste de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines à
l'agglomération au département à la
région
aujourd'hui ce qui est annoncé et c'est
effectivement la possibilité pour tous
les saint quentinois et avoir accès aux
données des trois accès gratuit qui plus
est gratuit en permanence d'accès aux
tueries de loisirs toutefois il peut y
avoir une réflexion au delà je sais
qu'il de loisirs elle même va faire ses
propres annonces sur les modalités
pratiques aussi de cet accès est ce
qu'il faut la carte de résident est ce
qu'on peut se présenter dès qu'un
justificatif de domicile